out of the many sharp films which haunt
our history
was born the unshakable determination
that respect for human life
liberty and well-being
must be
enshrined as rights are beyond the power
of any force to diminish
it's been exactly a quarter of a century
since nelson mandela signed south
africa's new constitution and made the
rainbow nation into a beacon on the
continent when it comes to lgbt rights
the document forbids discrimination on
grounds of sexual identity and so far
south africa is the only african nation
to allow same-sex marriage
all this means one thing for lgbt people
in the region
hope
they've come from across the continent
to join the parade the celebrations are
on for gay pride in pretoria
but it's not just about having fun for
arnold jason
he's here to fly the flag for lgbt
people back home
i come from zambia i wouldn't i'm not
even allowed to be here or whatsoever
but just being here
and for the zambian flag being flown in
the sky that gives hope to somebody
who's seated in zambia and yet they
could not attend an event like this one
south africa was a trailblazer for lgbt
people
both globally and in africa still the
only country on the continent to have
legalized same-sex marriage
but even here the community has its
concerns
it's like you take chances just for you
to come and march even to a country that
really pro that really acknowledges
queer rights and yet people do still shy
away because they are scared that no if
they do go back to their communities
they might be harmed in a certain way
the first african gay pride was held
here in south africa in 1990 and now
it's marched its way across africa
from nigeria to kenya and even to tiny
eswatini
but there is also anti-lgbt violence in
the rainbow nation
a survey by south african rights group
out revealed that half of black
respondents knew someone who had been
killed because of their sexual
orientation dw's reporter or kerin
gushing ado reports from cape town
ethan chigwada is a gay man and lives in
the township of langa here queer people
are confronted with verbal abuse and
violence
as i'm a drake
not far from here i was drinking
chilling with other friends of mine and
a man actually posed to me how can you
dress as a woman was a man
and he actually beaten me up
ethan fled from zimbabwe to seek refuge
in south africa after he had suffered
rape and constant harassment as a gay
man
now in south africa he does not feel
safe either south africa is supposed to
kind of protect us as lgbti people they
know the situation in them they know how
a person can be killed because of being
gay you can be imprisoned like all of
those sort of harassment and no one is
going to protect you
so you wouldn't expect
that in south africa but we are i'm
actually experiencing it south africa
has reported a speed in hate crimes
against the queer community
south africa's national tars team on the
rights of lgbt plus persons reported 30
murder cases since june last year but
experts believe that many more still go
unreported
during a trance rights gala in cape town
activists had a moment of silence and
led candles for the lives lost due to
hate crimes
there has been
quite a sharp rise in incidents that we
are covering
and it's a kind of cause for concern
uh i mean we talk about south africa
being this very kind of progressive
uh kind of legal framework with our
constitution which is really really
amazing
but time and time again the kind of
reality is that
those kind of mechanisms don't translate
into action on the ground a compacting
of hate crimes in speech bill was
approved by cabinet in 2018 but is yet
to be passed in parliament for ethan
drag offers strength and fierceness
something he will not stop regardless of
the risk it poses in langa all he wants
is to create a home in south africa and
fight for safety for himself and the
queer community
you